this week's videos are sponsored by manscaped
and Shopify more on them after the reaction
people oh my goodness citizens of the reject
Nation it's me Tara Ericson and Greg ala are
you rhyming or just saying it in a tone it whole
it was a Vibe is what it was I thought going to
rhyme he did not join in he did not yes and he did
the classic I said my name yes and he did Dead Pan
movie I guess anding was filling in the blank I'm
not having it you know what he was he was Pitch
Black and that's the movie we are watching today
Pitch Black in his soul cuz he didn't go with the
rhyming with me Pitch Black we're watching itday
there no Rhymes happen neither of us have seen
it or done a nope I can't do it I can't rhyme not
today guys sometimes I'm good at it today I'm not
you better leave a like you better leave a comment
for what just happened here I tried what the hell
happened and also don't forget weird bring aell
that's definitely the weirdest one ring it a bell
ring it a bell ring it a bell ring it a bell also
thanks to prepper for helping us edit down these
videos we call you super sexy if you join patreon
we get over there and we're like hey you're super
sexy we'll write you a w about being so sexy
and slap you in the ass slap you in the ass that
didn't rhyme either that's what he said he said
it first say slap on the ass slap on the ass we're
going right in there cuz if you join our patreon
we're going right up in there all right we're not
afraid to take risks sexy ones we love you a lot
do you need to update them on something cuz I'm
rocking and I'm rolling at this you are killing
it today now listen uh we're going to watch Pitch
Black it's got V diesel in it I'm a huge fan so
huge you haven't seen Pitch Black so huge he's a
huge man I'm a huge fan H that was a rhyme you
guys heard it right here are you talking about
that was I rhymed I said he's a huge man and I'm
a big fan okay you're right I did you did I wasn't
listening he what are you talking about he wasn't
even he's he's complaining about my rhyming he
doesn't even register it I can't it's a good first
video yeah we should watch the movie now huh yeah
he's so funny we're ready I'm pretty sure I'm your
you can seriously come with your own cop Gregory
is my only he's my only fan here on the channel
everyone El only fans and then there's only fan I
ter only he is my only fan everyone else is like
she's a lot she a lot to deal she's a lot she's
loud I'll addit the intro I'll be like I don't
know why I find this woman so funny I think she's
hilarious o right R okay I didn't
know that oh getting into it
now banana banana I hope this movie matches your
energy today it's called pitch black pretty sure
it won't except that's the color of my soul
okay who is that an actual like model not
CGI looks real oh my God even the text is
in Black this is like the opening of Space
Balls that looks pretty pretty awesome this a
'90s movie so apparently okay so there's three
of these this a '90s movie We're watching a
movie from the '90s this is a there's three
of them and I don't know anything about what
any of them were about they say most of your
brain shuts down and cry or sleep I believe
that all but the Primitive side that V voice
Bo has got me the animal side the survival
side no wonder I'm still awake transporting
me with civilians sounded like 40 40 plus oh
I miss Bleak Sci-Fi movies free settlers and
here's my real problem Mr John's planning on
taking me back to slam only this time he picked
a ghost Lane what an interesting way to set up
your characters a long time between stops long
time for something to going wrong also I'm
trying to get Vin Diesel to audiobook me to
sleep so everyone else gets to stay
asleep while he's semia awake not
anymore God his voice was so soothing I it's so
good oh what a cool POV reveal
oh damn oh oh waking and now
[Music] dead ouch it's my wife every
morning Captain's dead cor shows we at 22 weeks
out so gravity was not supposed to kick in for
another 19 why' I fall at all I love this
camera Jitter we're himring air something
took a swipe at us come on come on just tell me
what's still on the shipping Lan man just show
me all those Stars come on kind of makes you
feel like you're on a boat it's like not even
yeah it's like they're doing a a floating Vibe
oh I didn't know if you know this but when you
enter back into the atmosphere you get hot
oh really yeah yeah o we got it hey we got
it wowza this is
intense it's really bright this movie is a
liar yo these effects are
pretty cool recommend purging
B okay yeah like she had to pull like 17 handles
just then I know that makes it feel realistic when
you do it crisis program s number two in the
system because it shows at least some oxygen
maximum terrain 220 M over a mean surface Lely
Cinder and gipson with some evaporite deposits
you think when they go to pitch black the the
floating will stop I this is a little nausey
do oh is he like a criminal villain yeah
I think he's like somewh they transporting
okay company says we are responsible for
every single one of those people fry what
we both die out of sh ability don't you touch
that handle fry pull the 39th handle do it I
love that her name is fry I'm not going to
die for them lock doors I us still have 70
seconds to level this Beast out I love the Old
School production design of this interior not
secure oh oh what the is happen up
there how is she not sliced in dice
right now just a few glass particles in
her hair no problem wouldn't she just be
like burned like oh boy the glass that can
sustain that of heat you apparently can't
cut her whoa what a weird looking shot
what the hell what are they doing with
the frame this is when they were like we have
an anamorphic lens and we're going to use it
oh she's for sure dead now right yeah oh
whoa what a wild opening yeah so the only
ones survived were the ones in the boxes
right that's a safe presumption if she comes
out of the dirt I'm going to be like what which
she probably will cuz she is a '90s actor
that worked a lot so I don't feel like they
would kill her off I hope not the best looking
one on the crew she's very attractive is he a
902 and0 back in the day guy I'm not I'm not
your guy yeah I'm not I'm not my guy either
uhoh V Diesel's free but the next two movies are
named after his character so maybe he's like an
anti-hero
whoa ouch somebody's going to get hurt
one of these days and it going to be
me oh she is alive and fully Well w she looks
amazing yeah she looks great like she just took
a shower so I guess something went wrong oh
wow he wait dead I'm sorry looks like your EP
epidermis wasn't as imp penetrated oh my God
he's alive he's alive he's living don't touch
it don't get out of him no no no it's too close
to his heart there's some anesty in the Medlock
in the back of the cabin not anymore m not get
out of here I have to kill him now get out of
here what a weird reaction like
this is we're being weird about
this feel like she's having
a very human response right
now whoa it looks like they shot her on a bright
location then brightened it up even more they
raised those Shadows they raise those highlights
wow this is what you get what a weird looking film
interesting May because is a little old
it kind of looks like a concept film
that you'd see on YouTube yeah you're
right a very expensive one there was
talk of a scouting party looking
for other people but then we saw
this oh that scouting party
be dead his Beast wasn't made
to land like this but I think he did
well at least they landed on a place
with oxygen whole bloody container is
upside down it's all it's all Topsy to
now that is a neat place to store your [__]
I don't suppose this will help you at all
unfortunately it is not permitted especially
while on hot oh that's him oh Keith David
yeah now there's something kinky
about the way he's tied up yeah
and also what is that thing in his
[Music] mouth like the set Department
was like just get me any BDSM stuff
you have at home and let's lay it on
him what no
no whoa how did they do that that was an awesome
shot did do you think he actually knows how to
like dis no you can't do that you would die
that that was super cool he trained himself
to dislocate his shoulders it looks so real he
was so committed I mean if the man is gone he's
gone why should he bother us maybe to take what
you got maybe to work your nerves this guy or
maybe it just come back and sculpt you in your
sleep he's my favorite character everyone is
an arch type but I'm not used to seeing these
Arch types put together excuse me I think you
should say this three sons yo there is something
very odd about the way this movie is edited yeah
what that looks very green screen we take this as
a good sign path direction from all it's a bit of
a bad sign that's Rick's Direction I thought you
found his restraints over there towards Sunset
which means he went towards Sunrise do they
need ridic they haven't really explained it
that's why he's like just let him go what happens
if Mr rck spots us first there'll be no shots oh
they got to take him alive interesting how the
tint and the color of this now it's blue but
why the change oh cuz now we're in his point
of view it's a good guess trees trees being
water I love how Bleak and serious this is
yet simultaneously cheesy yeah it's like
fun cheesy with this dark aesthetic
I wonder if the coloring is to hide
because it's not real like there's a green
screen back there yeah than that it looks
real probably get you right here and you never
even hear him coming cuz that's how good rck is
tell me something did you run away from your
parents or did they run away from you I love
that line okay just to reestablish the plot of
this movie is they're they're hunting for Ric
and they're trying to figure out where they are
and survive yeah I don't know why they need Ric
maybe he's their like pet killer oh my God is that
a dinosaur I love dinosaurs is this whole planet
dead oh man if we don't get some
terrible CGI creatures I'm going
to be very [Music] disappointed that's a pretty
cool like set right here like what we're looking
at is I like it oh is he just asleep or hiding
he looked like he was asleep his body language
looked like he was passed out I think we should
keep moving what Owens mean I'm not touching the
handle this dude just oh that was
shot he's going I'm not your captain he's that
close yall don't feel him there he's the one
that stopped the docking pilot from dumping the
main [Music] cabin see Owen and the docking p it
being did he just take a
piece of her hair like did she
yes maybe he sees things
differently I'm into it this is one of
the oddest things I've seen in a while
yeah this is really odd and this like set that
they built is pretty awesome anyone here okay
so it would appear that some type of creature
has annihilated some of the former inhabitants
but then why are they also all dead all the
creatures Allah abbar this is the source of the
water hello MEA love how exasperated that
guy constantly [Music] looks it's their own
Millennial [Music] Falcon yeah is this the way
R I think this the way Ric sees sees like is he
like okay so he's like oh oh my God I thought I
was the only one who got out of the crash of life
oh uh it was just somebody else in the
crash Cy I thought it was him I thought
it was to take him alive so you made two
mistakes oh my God H this movie what is
this film I have not quite latched
on to what the toone is I don't know
either he is so relaxed and just hiding
in plain sight like nobody's business
what the oh there's a creature what is
that what what
[Music]
what
dam it wasn't Ric his blade is unbloodied
oh yeah you're right it is how he sees okay what
did you do to Z what did you do to damn V diesel
getting his asset this would not happen to
his contracts now so where's the body well
do you want to tell me me about the sounds
I feel like every every cut to a new scene
lapses like 10 to 15 minutes in time you don't
want to talk to me that's your choice but just
so you know there's a debate right now as to
whether we should just leave you here to die
you mean The Whispers The Whispers I mean that's
how he talks he talks in a whisper what Whispers
the wind's telling me to go for this sweet spot
just to the left of the spine fourth Lumber down
the abdominal aor it's a metallic taste human
blood but if you cut it with peppermint snaps
that goes away of course you want to shop me
with the truth now okay so he's some type of
He's Not Human Show Me Your Eyes Ric you'd have
to come a lot closer for that so he's going to
be the he's going to be the one to help protect
them against these aliens and protect her heart
who's this director there's so much like style
choices oh God where the hell can I get eyes
like that got to kill a few people okay I can
do it you got to get sent to a slam where they
tell you you never see daylight again oh this
happened to him you pay him 20 Menthol cools
to do a surgical shine job on your eyeballs
so you can see you sneaking up on you in the
dark exactly leave what a great way to get an
exposition did I kill Zeke no he's not in the
hole we looked look deeper he's just a mush of
blood this is how R gets rid of everyone they
just all keep this hole the hole like bye-bye
[Music] now I don't know why they're not like
well rck go in there show us drag the body out
it's dark in there it'll be great for your eyes
yeah I really wonder if this director did
music videos before there's so much like
the shot choices yeah you could tell that I could
tell this director likes a lot of things and is
trying to include a lot of things but there's not
really a succinct tone or Rhythm there's not like
a through line in regards to style yeah yeah
it's kind of a mishmash kind of all derivative
things they're Hollow is that a creature behind it
is what is that whoa it's a land [Laughter]
octopus oh girl you better get
going they look like starfish octopus is
that the way they see things when when the
camera that anamorphic Choice oh that's a
huge climb what happened to the Rope did it
break and I wasn't aware oh I think she's
coming out a different different side got
it not anymore oh boy I'm in here I'm [Applause]
inside please can you hear me come on little boy
find the [Music] hole can rck like
sense them I feel like he [Music]
can whoa I heard you fry I heard you my sake I
found his foot I don't know what the is in there
whatever it is it got Zeke and it nearly got me
oh did they take off the Rope I I just assumed
they took off the Rope yeah why wouldn't they do
that come on y'all just cut it at this point good
lord it's a waste of a good Rope though finally
found something worse than me huh so here's a
deal again just like the time jumps every every
scene just a time Jump as I'm tired of chasing
you you saying you'd cut me loose I'm thinking
you could have died in Crash my recommendation do
me ghost me mother that's what I would do to you
[Music] damn Vin Diesel used to know how to really
deliver these lines in a way that did not sound
cheesy you mean right now delivering I like damn
this badass as hell yeah yeah especially in the
beginning dialogue I was like oh damn Vin Diesel
I If that had to do with direction or his choice
it's great yeah he's just kind of like you know
yeah do we have a deal want you to
remember this moment the moment I let you
live yeah man this director loves to experiment
with his DP the coloring is what's like the most
wild to me from the bright orange to the
blue to the then regularly colored maybe
this is when people started getting access to
computer editing programs and they were like
let's try them all all right all right
my T my are they act working on getting
off this planet I don't know honestly
they were working on water for a minute
okay you're missing the party I need to start
saying that on all my dates missing the party come
on this is it gives me a headache I don't
know why remember that Ghost Rider 2 movie
we saw that like crazy one I feel like it's
kind of similar for the way have odd odd Vibe
odd choices nice of them to leave so much
stuff here why' they leave their ship they
didn't leave their ship they were killed
remember those land squid you had to fight
off yeah lady these people didn't leave
come on who got Zeke got them they're all
dead that's rude rck maybe they had weight
limits you don't know I know you don't prep
your emergency ship unless it's aing emergency
right I love the kid I love this copy [Applause]
cat BS they have a hard time hearing gunshots but
they can hear that kid screaming I don't
want it hey this is how Batman came to
be that look like a pretty cool effect what's
he trapped in with right now Jack wait wait
Alie I'm so fascinated about how
this movie kickstarted a franchise
and now it's called pitch plaque
it hasn't even been pitch plaque
yet than do all those little things
become one big thing or are they
food for the big thing oh or maybe it's
more like alien which this movie seems
very much to be aping where they have
like little ones and then big ones yeah
oh that transition I can't that is an old
that what the hell why was that transition
like that it really like I made the joke of
them being like let's use them all all but
I feel like that is exactly what they're
doing these cing samples are dated last
one's 22 years ago this month okay is there
something special about that car this really
does feel like something you would see on
the Sci-Fi channel oh absolutely at like 1
in the morning that's probably why they got a A
series everyone on the Sci-Fi channel was like
more Eclipse uh-huh You're Not Afraid of the
Dark are you I mean Vin Diesel is the best
part of the movie yeah he really is by and
large look you told me that we could trust
you said that we had a deal John didn't
say we could trust as far as I can tell
he hasn't even lied to us let's just stick
to the deal John he's a killer and the law
says he has to do his bid there is nothing
I can do about that you hear me oh self
serious slowmo close-ups of that I don't want
it pull a handle make it the 41st one strange
not doing a run up on the main drive yet unless
he told you the particulars of my Escape he
literally just didn't you think John is a
do right man you think I could trust
him to cut me loose why what did you
he play a
cool I am worth twice as much alive oh you didn't
know that you're John's and a cop he's got that
nickel slick bad man he's a bounty hunter don't
waste my time we're not going to turn on each
other no matter how hard you try this must have
been fun to watch it when it first came out when
you would wonder is Vin Diesel really a bad guy
or a good guy but I think like watching it now
you're like well he's obviously a good guy ever
wonder why John shakes like that ask him and ask
why your crew palow had to scream so painfully
before he died it's a fair point these are fair
questions he's bringing new info is johon dying
and he needs money that's why I bring reick back
but also how does that tie to the way the guy
screamed so that when he died I don't know I
don't know oh or also is he a drag at okay yeah
maybe they like performance enhancers oh my God
what are we looking at what are we doing oh yeah
he's a drug addict so he puts it in his eyes so
you can't tell not a cop are you I never said
was SC how'd you get on the ship what does the
ship consist of who are the people on this crew
yeah and why are we did we miss a line cuz I feel
like we haven't talked over any of the important
stuff Owens was already dead his brain just hadn't
caught on to the fact is there anything else I
should know about you John I'm just a cool Cowboy
man I'm not your captain it's going to be her
character Arc she's going to
uh realize that she she is a
leader we're getting close to the eclipse that
they showed us on the on the model right if we
need anything from the crash ship I suggest
we kick on that sandat solar Clips sand okay
yeah alien creatures I feel like Mad Max watched
this movie and was like there's some aspects of
it we like but we're going to redo it I feel
better I think flip that because they Cally
watch Mad Max first I know but this one came
out before so I'm like didn't they have they
had like the goggles the kind of car look no
no Mad Max came out with the Mel Gibson ones
first oh [__] you're right never mind
they took yes and then they didn't they
didn't really whoa whoa that's a cool shot
that looks pretty awesome surpris you're um
human wise responding with adverse effects to
being so close to these things right like how
are they not yeah how is their bodies and
blood and brain not being affected they're
superhuman symbolic for his [Music] balls
it's getting so dark it's getting pitch
black up in here almost wow that's a
lot of them holy this is like demonic
now like flying [Music] whoa this's
some stranger things juice right
here that's a pretty cool shot yeah
it's becoming a supernatural movie now
yeah get down get
down wow getting down actually allowed
them to dodge it it worked worked it's
like what you do in a fire except
what you do with flying octopi is
the same crawl stay down yeah I would
be just crawl oh well girl oh my God
okay they ate her
in WoW more of that movie do more of that that
was cool off them what is this sound oh do you
think that's claymation yeah these look like
little models little model yeah that's cool
his eyes oh look at the little clay model oh my
God what's growing that is neat I could see why
in his perspective he thought it was beautiful
[Music] yeah finally pitch black the rest of
this movie is an audible experience if she
only would have stayed down she'd be okay she
wouldn't have died you remember the Boneyard
Bard this might be that killed every living
thing on this planet yes yes we might have
drawn that conclusion 1 hour ago ourselves as
audience members yeah why do they do that make
that sound perhaps they're communicating it's
the way they see sonar type of site so they
just have to wait for the eclipse to pass I
guess interesting to have Keith David
here after starring in the thing with
yeah have you seen Doctor Who no no okay I
need to watch it though I he it's a great
show can't really uh go into the commentary
with you if you haven't seen it you're over
there on your own whoa that looks
like a dragon dinosaur a dinosaur
dragon dragonaur Dino dragon that that works
way better Dino Dragon was the right [Music]
move cool [Music]
alien two competing night [Music]
visions oh because this movie is
so dark you can get away with
this visual effects really well
right that looked kind of dumb but in
the begin ah whoa that little boy be
murdered oh whoa that looks pretty
cool all right so you just need more bullets
you see like thousands more bullets yeah I mean
he's still got that the flamer on I would
just I would flame it light actually hurts
them Ni no good that's also Ric's weakness
anything over 45 proof Burns rather well how
many bottles you got I don't know maybe 10
make a Molotov cocktail kill all those dra
Dino dragons now how long can this last I had
the impression from the model the two planets
were moving as one and there would be a lasting
Darkness oh oh great what are yall going to do
it's going to be 20 years man oh maybe that's
why those skeletons were in there cuz they had
to weigh out the the 20e clipse that makes a
lot of sense actually how much you weigh John
around 79 kilos to you're 79 kilos of gutless
white meat and that's why you can't think of a
better if you want to keep your your hooa
I mean sit back down sir he could blow
your head off before you cut yeah but just even
one little prick up there buddy Dam come on now
this is like a sketch
troop they they're just all so such
a weird Ensemble of characters looks
clear
what you said clear I said it looks
clear that is true he did not speak
so definitively what what's it look like now
looks clear that the funniest part of this
movie I feel like they've been continually
working on stuff and I don't know what
they're working on I mean now running about 10
Paces ahead I want light on my back but not on
my eyes Okay and check your Cuts they're
building weapons to combat them I think
okay but even before you remember we saw the
same items they're thrown around my biggest
issue is I'm not emotionally invested in
anyone yeah no no we don't care if they
really let them all die I kind of like the
captain are you ready John look we're just
wasting lot here you give them the C in the
ship and they leave you all out there to die
VN Diesel's arm looks real nice I know man
that vein dang dude Popp oh God yeah popping
oh cool every 10 minutes this movie takes a break
to go is Ric going to be good or
bad in the end what's it going to
be wait you're away from the
light get back [Music] here a where
is he going buddy why I people who
panic and go Rogue in these situations bug
the crap out of me oh great you killed us
[Applause] all I mean it was bound to
happen but you got to see this awesome
Planet whoa that was cool it's great
that was awesome do I even want to
know do I even want to know put it
together you know what's happening
that's death row up there especially with
the girl bleeding she's not cut not her
her oh my God this movie is Progressive well
I was going to make the comment that I was
like he looks trans and the voice like was very
obviously presenting his female and I was like
oh this is Advanced for the '90s well the movie
now gets a 10 out of 10 for me in Casey have a
notice they go off blood look this is not not
going to work cuz of period see that's when he
said cut I was like is she actually cut or did
she just start our period That's what I'm yeah
do we have to specify that that it it's a woman I
know right my life's Su steeming pile of meaning
this [__] anyhow so I say mush on the Cane's
only a couple hundred meters and after that it's
skip City so why don't you butch up stuff for
corking this kid let's go oh it is because of
her period during the crash she tried to blow
the whole passenger cabin tried to kill us in
our sleep shut your mouth we are disposable
wait what blow hi hi how much do you weigh
now veric in light moves forward this guy's
the worst yeah he's giv so much screen time
too I don't like he was on I swear to God cuz
he's famous when this movie came out that guy
yes he's was in a TV show I think it's 90210 I
can't stand him you can't stand his character
or his act acting his character a little bit
of both okay I wanted to clear it up and see
you do the girl I'll keep fethers off your back
hey he he don't roll that way no he don't do
that now is your time to go Broski I'm just
wondering if I don't need a bigger piece of
B leave this let's move rck you ain't so
bad oh wow I don't understand how this
guy puts up such a good fight against
rck well cuz he's the actual Bounty
Hunter right I think yeah but still
like Ric is is a predator like the
most predominant lethal dude because
they need him to put up a fight for
the movie Greg what what stay in the
light come on rck you can do
it no
you one Brave before you Billy badass the
Gage man V diesel was really cool in this
byebye now morphine guy oh don't Rob us of this
movie I want to see it we want to see Ric do
it cool that was cool watch Ric touch yourself Ric
whoa yes waa that was awesome that was very
cool best part of the movie killing this guy
back to the ship huh away tell you can't see
what's eating you that the big plan where's
John's which half great response cuz you do
not believe in God does not mean God does not
believe in someone can spend half their life in a
slam I absolutely believe in God absolutely hate
the no you are not Dominic Tera that way it's the
only way off this rock just keep the girl between
you damn he's gone from Criminal
to Captain himself wow all
[Music] right oh good dodging Ric
yeah also I would be just like light
lighting them up just light him on
fire do not look go listen listen
to [Music] Ric why are they killing each
other because there's not enough humans to
eat it's going to be okay [Music]
Terra
R cares about the girl it's just
mushing its head into the ground
it's trying to attack oh wow yeah burn it
throw that Molotov cocktail right in its
mouth whoa what just happened BL SP
cool wa get the blind [Music]
spot what am I looking at I don't
nobody knows he's turning around
and he's gutting it okay did not know who
was I didn't like that line that seemed a little
too corny except that will probably be the quote
that everyone quotes from this movie did not know
he who he was with so where the hell's your God
now that's a what where the hell's your God
now oh cuz clearly God doesn't love them to
put out their fire because of the rain
just tell me that the settleman is right
there you can't make it after all that saving
your ass yeah see you later buddy hide here
now
I'm so glad that one guy's dead you hated
him I thought he really dragged the movie
down man that's what morphine does it
drags you down man oh my God is he going
to go get the ship himself maybe yeah good
finally let's see those Vin Diesel muscles
just move around take your shirt off come on
buddy he's not coming back back is he oh he
is it's his character he's going to crash
through that mountain with the [Applause]
ship oh they glow it is beautiful they now
see things the way Ric sees what is this is
this slugs like babies oh is this like their uh
Whatchamacallit like a caterpillar like a a worm
like um cocoon cocoon like are they cocoons
with little babies in them and the babies
glow okay smart wow how convenient that those
things are right there for them to just put in
their [__] bottles yeah like we're probably
not going to find out what they are right that
they just decided to Glow at the last second
that's why they have the conversations about
God cuz God was gifting them with that oh
right okay and rck is their savior leading
them through the promised land let's get
your neon glow sticks and let's [Music]
roll you're taking too long to stare at him
centrally get in the ship and let's go make
love and then go yeah optional there's got to
be some part of you that wants to rejoin the
human race truthfully I wouldn't know how
well then just give me more live for them
I'll go back by myself there you go please
just come in you just said a go by yourself
step inside here I'll make it easy come on
love how taunting he is I don't understand
why he didn't just like go back he give him
a light like because it took a lot of work
to get this far and it's too dangerous to go
back why didn't he just say that then he just
seems [Music] mean oh she's got PTSD oh yeah
the handles they're definitely PTSD for me me
too you listen to me I am the captain of this
ship all right there we have it you died I went
how interesting that was the first time I felt
any bit of emotion in this entire I agree that
that that was good I like that part other than
laughing things are admiring and for anyone not
ready for this that is my God Mr [Music] CRI now
let's rage movie has been progressively better
ever since we got rid of that one guy yes I do
agree think terrible character I kind of like
his thrown away Cowboy aspect yeah you would
that's why youve date kind of menu [Laughter]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] date oh my God
they're holding hands so so sweet it's about
family
okay oh weak spot like they're
all for oh no okay cool that
worked only Ric would understand how their Vision
Works I don't understand how
they navigate how the do you
see through something like that that is [Music]
impossible lure it
away smart see a
cool kill each
other R how cruel would that have
been if they just left him hey
face no pick him up how did Ric
survive that did they just bite his
[Applause] leg what oh who was
stabbed was she stabbed I I guess by
him oh by the thing okay oh damn a that's
[Music] sad well that was actually kind of
sad yeah this movie got me to care about
her in the last 10 minutes of this movie
also quite ironic how she said I said I'd
Die For them not for you and There She
Goes is he gonna be like we have
to get the body what's he doing
PR what you doing he's got to
get her body and pay respects
right them he's going to burn them yeah
I love that hell yeah hell yeah you can't
leave got say good
night
whoa well done that's a pretty shot it's just
so interesting to see what vendel is now like
the Trope of vend diesel now yeah to back then
where I'm like I could take this seriously of him
yeah me too just kind of goofy now I feel like in
the first fast and furious he was the he was good
yeah whoa what that's an awesome shot that that
feels [Music] cool all right toi
David toi how was this movie so
big I don't know maybe because there wasn't a
lot going on when this was released in sci-fi
or just in general there wasn't a lot going
on so everyone was about it Mary balls Miss
reject Nation you know what the funny thing is I
already owned this product before agreeing to do
this partnership I could have used my influencer
ring to get it for free or at a discount but hey
now you can get it at a discount cuz this week we
are of course sponsored by manscape as a married
man who's always on the move I value looking sharp
while keeping things efficient and that's where
manscapes performance package 5.0 Ultra comes
in featuring the lawn mower 5.0 and it is a
game changer the package is honestly a perfect
gift for yourself or for another man that you
might know I'll give this to John if anyone ask I
pay for it out of my own pocket but no seriously
this is easily the best because it comes with not
one but two NextGen blade heads see the difference
it's good thing I have two now for demonstration
purposes so you got the standard trimmer for a
perfect neat trim but this one the new foil blade
for that super smooth finish and oh yeah it's all
about safe grouping with their Advanced Skin safe
technology plus they're waterproof so no more
crumbs on the carpet the package also includes the
weed whacker 2.0 for ear and nose and I definitely
use this because look at me I'm a hairy guy and
the must have liquid formations the crop Soother
After Shave lotion and the crop preserver ball
deodorant say goodbye to postet of irritation and
hello freshness and the ultimate cherry on top two
free gifts manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and the
[__] 2.0 toiletry bag again I already have one
the boxers I'm wearing my pair right now and the
bag is perfect for all your grooming Essentials
as you can see so you're ready to elevate your
grooming game head to manscape.com and use code
reject for a cool 20% off plus free shipping
remember it's rejects for 20% off at manscape.com
let's get those jingle balls holiday ready with
manscaped thank you to Shopify for sponsoring
which is what we use for our merch store and is
our gamechanging partner in e-commerce so whether
you're launching a passion project or scaling to
new heights Shopify is e-commerce Powerhouse
guiding you at every step from creating your
first online store to opening physical locations
Shopify makes it seamless it's perfect whether
you're selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their all-encompassing
platform for both online and inore sales their
checkout system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors to buyers than other
platforms and let's not forget Shopify magic
the AI tool that elevates your business with
minimal effort but seriously reflecting on our
journey using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition smooth
growth exponential thank you again reject Nation
from simplifying sales to scaling our offerings
Shopify has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers 10% of
us e-commerce backing businesses big and small
in over 175 countries there are warwin support
always there to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a dollar
a month at shopify.com rejects all overc case
shopify.com rejects start your Shopify success
story now let's grow together with Shopify team
oh that mie gave me a headach every time I tried
to take it seriously like I was really I made a
wow 2000 2000 one year after the Matrix I made
a concerted effort and then even out of 10 on
IMDb that's like no people really like it and I
that's seven I mean I would maybe I kept trying
man I would maybe go seven out of 10 I guess to
be like there's some cool effects I love me some
Vin Diesel the monsters were very very cool like
once we got to the to the dino dragons it was cool
and especially when he the one shot when he drinks
the the thing and then he blows it through the the
lighter and you see all them light up like there's
some definite cool shots in here that I was like
that's awesome and so inventive uh um but yeah I
I mean I think uh like we both were saying if
anything doesn't if there's not a heart to the
story I don't like it like we I think we felt that
way with despicable three something was some other
movie we talked about this to dri no I know it's
terrible no I was just I was thinking about the
movies the last movies we watch that we said we
didn't like CU it didn't have as much heart in it
and this one except for at the end of you know of
her dying we did start to care but as you said in
the beginning we didn't care really about any of
them from the top it was mainly just look at this
movie because it's sci-fi and it looks different
sure um and there's this guy that we're all trying
to figure out whether he's good or not Ric and
what is he going to do and then random creatures
around there yeah I mean the through line of it
was not strong but um still interesting and I
liked I like the monsters a lot espec I like the
end like if they had if they had started at the
end where they were already with the monsters and
like we got to find our spaceship right I would
have loved that movie way more like start towards
the middle of this movie and keep going and like
maybe she dies and now we have to still live with
rck and the guy and I don't know some other stuff
I would have really enjoyed that that would have
been a good move listen I'm just telling you how
to rewrite it toi yes go back do what I just said
maybe maybe Hawk it up to a nine I want to see
because it's interesting because this one's like
called pitch black yeah and the sequel is called
The Chronicles of R so that's different and then
the third one is just called called Ric so I feel
like Vin Diesel gained power and was going yes
make this more about me more about me so much so
that we're not even going to call the third one
Chronicles RCT 3 we're going to just call it he
probably obviously became the the an executive
producer by the time the chronicles of R came
out he was like let's spin my character off from
this cuz he probably really liked playing it um I
did I did believe him the acting didn't bug me as
much as it did Greg with that one with the other
guy 90210 and the blonde girl I recognize her
she was a strong like 90s early 2000s actress
and I can't remember her name but I really liked
vend diesel this especially when he first starts
speaking in his voiceover role which is why I was
making the joke can he please do an audio book and
vend diesel me to sleep because it was so soothing
and it's also a voice that and a tone that I don't
hear from Vin Diesel from at all anymore and I
really like that um that's I thought he yeah was
just like relaxed and not as corny except for
that one line but that's not his fault that was
just one line that I think I said it and I don't
remember what it was because that's my brain that
I thought was a little corny when the thing died
um but anyhow I would I would probably with the
monsters and stuff give it probably a seven seven
out of 10 wow that's still very kind I know it's
like I want to go six and a half but I'm like with
the monsters and how they look do bring it back up
but the stories the story I'll give it a six it's
just it's really just the monsters and the ending
of it for me and the cool way that they worked
with light in it I did enjoy I did enjoy how when
rdick goes to kill the guy that the music swelled
in a different way I like that well I anyway tear
it apart take it away Greg I'm not going to tear
it apart I think this movie it has um um a lot I
think it's very derivative of a lot of other
Sci-Fi movies there's going to be a ridic in
2024 yeah they announced it apparently I was I
found that out okay um Ric Furia what the hell
does that mean yeah soar cly like the the world of
Ric is Big so it's got a fan base man it's got a
fan base and I know fandoms can be very sensitive
I understand this so let's just I'm going to kind
of rate everything out scale I think production
design is my probably the one quality of this
that I enjoyed the most I like the sets I liked um
a lot of the practicality to it and I would give
that like a a n out of 10 right there I agree with
that I like the sleaziness were cool it was really
cool Vin Diesel I thought was excellent because
it's like it's pitch black we're just doing this
one sci-fi movie now we're gonna make an a Ric
franchise you know and I could see how taking this
character I I totally get the choice to go let's
not do a pitch black to because it would just be
a repetitive premise to go after these nameless
creatures and and all that and focus on Ric I
understand that because Vin Diesel is excellent in
this movie he is he is excellent uh what is that
actress's name who her character was growing on me
as we went yeah she she's she's a great uh she's a
great actor she works all the time yeah yeah Roda
Mitchell oh that's her name yeah I just know her
from all a ton of movies she works constant yeah
yeah she she's a she's but also did the director
did I just see that the director and the writer of
pitch black wrote GI Jane because that's a great
script wrote gii Jane wrote The Fugitive yeah uh
he WR some great movies writer I mean wrote Water
World oh look at him wrote terminal velocity wow
I mean wrote the arrival oh no I'm thinking I'm
thinking I was think arrival arrival the arrivals
withle sh yes you're right um that's crazy to me
those are some good yes yeah he's some good stuff
but you know it's ultimately a director's movie
in the end absolutely y um so I I liked that
the action I would put it the action I would
give like a five the violence I would give like
a seven mhm the music I surprisingly liked didn't
comment on it at all during the film um the music
I would probably give like an eight there was that
I thought that helped keep a pace to it yeah the
editing I'm very conflicted on yeah that's I mean
they went into some shots where it just went in
remember with the eyeballs where eyeball a lot of
it felt like afterthought choices in post like
you're messing with footage and let's do this
let's just do it yeah yeah a lot a lot of it felt
like that or maybe it really CU is he also the WR
he's the writer and director of it so maybe all
of them it looks like maybe he just had a vision
and this is what happens when when he's like I
finally have control over my screenplay here's
the weird eccentricities that really pop up in my
mind that I I can't put down in my script here's
what I really wanted to do with the futa but
then they changed it up you know here the weird
perspectives I wanted they didn't kill a body and
lay down the skull and then transition into where
a light comes through the eye and into a a whole
view of the sun cuz that's what happened here they
made some bold choices like the editing was so
like there was the the thing is I I I would say
the directing and editing um was such a mixed bag
for me because as much as I appreciated intent on
style it was so such a surface experience and
the surface of it initially I was like oh this
is going to be interesting like I love the opening
scene honestly the crash was was gripping it was
frantic uh I really like that opening and then
when it uh started to become the movie is what I
started to like what's happening here like why is
it so Overexposed when they're on the land I get
it because it's the solar eclipse when is pitch
black but still like the that did make me go like
it wasn't as great to look at yeah it it felt
and it granted it was 2,000 but then again you
know Matrix was like a year before and that film I
think still looks great there are some parts that
that look dated but still looks great for a heavy
heavy Sci-Fi Action film this is a different kind
of movie um and but however I I do think that
there's a lot of things in here that did feel
cheap for a universal film and like it did feel
like a b movie and I think the best compliment you
could pay is like it feels like an above average
Sci-fi channel movie absolutely the Sci-Fi channel
went on and that's why it can continue yeah and I
could see how it can gather that fan base because
of what it's derivative of the things that plays
on uh tropes and whatever I I think that it it
it just didn't really have a a sense of atmosphere
to me that I it didn't evoke the the things it was
playing on didn't ultimately evoke the emotion and
mood that it needed to in order for the things it
was playing on to ultimately work like there's no
real dread it's not intense it's not suspenseful
there's no wonder there's like I'm trying to
think of like the opposite emotions of those
there's there's nothing there where even even
what it's ultimately building to it is not quite
doesn't quite make you don't quite know where it's
building to yeah yeah exactly until it it seemed
like the were it was rushing to get to where the
darkness consumes the planet and that's about
close to an hour into the movie and they don't
introduce the eclipse thing until 5 minutes before
that happens and I think that's where the because
it the movie didn't start to really breathe or
have a real voice around it until we entered pitch
black terrain right which just I was like start
the movie there yeah like get get there quicker or
or glue Us in that we that's where we're leading
yeah I agree um but the hour pre uh preceding
it um no pre preluding right right preceding
righted proceed I thought proceeding would mean
proceedings yeah proceedings after no following
pre the pre proceeding means like the yeah the pre
the antecedent that means before okay okay is what
he's talking about the antecedent the one hour
prior prior to the part that we started to like
just rub me the kept kept rubbing me the wrong
way and I kept trying to give it a shot and and
before I knew it I was like Up N movie you lost
me too much cuz I'm like I've been here for an
hour I don't give a [__] about anyone here yeah
like I I don't care about anyone here and and uh I
thought they had a it's a cool concept man you
got to survive the night it's like you got to
survive the darkness with these nocturnal alien
creatures with your one person who can protect
you it's the criminal can you trust who can who
has nocturnal sight abilities as well and then
you got your main character it just lacked focus
and it's kind of surprising from the person who
wrote it to also direct it who has clearly written
some great scripts before to really lack a focus
here yeah and and that was the part of it that
I find most baffling because yeah you had a cool
setup with the characters and the creatures and
the world and conceptually there's a lot of very
interesting things here idea wise there's a lot
of interesting things and I can't I and all when
all is said and done I can see how you can build
a Ric franchise because you have space exploration
you don't really know this guy's backstory you
don't really know where he comes from there is
things that you can do with the character where
you can take it in a different direction where
it doesn't even have to like mood-wise follow what
this movie did right so I would be curious to see
The Chronicles of not saying we're going to watch
it but but I would be curious only due to the fact
that uh I really liked vinia overall that's uh for
the amount of hype I've heard around this I I am I
can't say I I overall enjoyed I'm like a I'm like
like a five four and 5.5 out of it I mean I get it
story is not great I wasn't I'm like but start
in the middle and keep going I liked it yeah I
mean and I love I love me some V diesel those
muscles oh man he looked great hello yeah cuz
I didn't start to care about anybody until like
the last 15 minutes until the last like when she
starts to die and she's like yes I would die for
them that was like the last five minutes um except
for when they when he when the guy that you hate
was saying go kill the girl and I'll watch her
back um you started to kind of feel for the girl
of like when she's like oh I've hidden you know
hidden my identity away because it'd be better to
get away as a guy would keep her safe or whatever
Mulan yeah yeah exactly uh which I like that turn
there but I feel like that even that reveal could
have been could have meant more could have like
felt it more but I didn't it was just like oh
yeah I mean I I was literally five minutes before
she said that I was going to make a comment saying
I feel like this boy is transed because he's
presenting with a girl's voice he does come
off still as a female very much to me so I was
wondering what the casting Choice was and then
yes it was finally revealed but we didn't really
care very much about that turn and we should have
um we did care a little bit that she was like
I would I would uh yes I would die for them she
convinces him to go back and then when she dies
was like oh all right that sucks there's a lot
of there's one thing when you like leave things
up for the audience to fill in the fill it in
that makes it more effective and there's a lot of
things where I can see people justifying stuff or
using their imagination to come up with things
because like they have elements here where you
can see a heart even if it feels cliche I would
have preferred the cliche honestly of like why
is she so attached to Ric and wanting to emulate
her whole personality off of R like I wanted to
I would want to know that zero in on that then do
something with it the whole time I just felt like
there's no real chemistry with anyone here and
some might justify that going was because a lot
of them are strangers I'm like well you can still
feel chemistry amongst actors in an ensemble and
and uh yeah just it it it felt like a lot of um
uh listless Mello drama I was watching like just
very un effective melod drama when I didn't really
feel the drama until like the last few minutes of
the film where it just finally felt like real
scene workor and not not actors in different
movies talking to each other like the the the even
them just walking through the locations and in the
beginning there could have been side conversations
about that girl and why she might be presenting
as as another person and why this guy is here
with his two kids and where does he come from
doesn't have to take a lot of time but would give
us something as to like maybe why they're they're
in a disagreement or maybe why hey [__] off I'm
here with my kids because of so and because of so
and so reason which would give us a little more
of a backstory so that we cared about them as a
whole as a unit so as we started to lose them
and that wouldn't take too much time we did we
did some just looking at stuff a lot and a lot of
repeat of like we've got to move and we got to get
this stuff together um that yeah I just feel like
if they had dug in a little bit more with each
character when we start to lose them it it might
have made the movie raise up from a I don't know
30% on Rotten Tomatoes to more than that whatever
it is it's actually the oh it's 59% the highest
rated one out of out of the and Chronicles of Ric
only has 65 okay Chronicles Chronicles Ric has
second highest audience score I don't like this
rating here because gi. Jane is at 53% and y'all
I like that movie that movie is fun I mean give me
a break 53% the oh God the fugitive is 89% yeah he
didn't he do you know who directed it well I'm
sure it's somebody great right cuz he only wrote
it red Le Scott oh that's why there we have it
it's great see that's why I just go GI Jane is a
great film and I I didn't even know who directed
it but I knew it's good and I'm like 53% get out
of here with that um anyway yeah I I would I would
I agree with all the the points that Greg was
rating it low for a lot of stuff but high for Vin
Diesel and the set design very cool the monsters
as I said dope love it um yeah I mean I don't
that's all I got to say about this movie I don't
I don't know much more except I would maybe give
Chronicles reic a try I just wouldn't be looking
forward to it I wouldn't I wouldn't sit down and
go can't wait I be like I need candy for this
movie and maybe a possible beer or a glass of wine
there we have it I need ibuprofen can we end the
video that too I mean it did kind of give me it's
that floating yeah the movie just like I just not
there's a lot going irritated me he's irritated
I feel all right but I'm always walking around
with a headache so you know yeah you operate at
headache level I do that's your secret cap that's
it I mean leave us a like leave us a comment tell
us how you like it I don't think people are going
to leave likes I'm pretty sure your most dislike
leave leave a like about us you know because we're
cool we're here we're taking a time from our day
to watch a movie with y'all so you know be be cool
be nice be kind be awesome and you know do you
got any last words what are you looking up he's
looking up I'm going to watch the Chronicles or
Ric trailer trer and then we'll uh and then we'll
decide if we'll watch it if it yeah but we're not
going to do that on camera no we will not but you
got some inside juice right there you guys will
see maybe we'll watch the other one let us know
if we should we love you so much and we will
see you on the next one bye-bye [Music] bye